und es geht weiter in sachen
außerirdisches leben mit dem trabant lhs
11 40 b haben forscher jetzt den bisher
chancenreichsten planeten entdeckt um
darauf außerirdisches leben zu finden er
bietet nicht nur die bisher besten
bedingungen diese super erde ist auch
perfekt dafür geeignet es zu entdecken
warum das so ist und warum er sogar in
jeglicher hinsicht besser dafür geeignet
ist als die planeten im system treff ist
wann die ja erst vor kurzem für furore
gesorgt haben jetzt den klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen es
war ja vor wenigen wochen eine riesige
sensation dass mit show bis wann ein
sternensystem gefunden wurde in dem
sieben planeten um einen roten zwerg
stern kreisen und drei davon sogar in
der habitablen zone also in dem bereich
in dem leben möglich wäre doch bislang
gibt es ein problem das leben unmöglich
machen könnte der stern im zentrum ist
wohl ziemlich aktiv krieg zum zuschauer
alpha duplo hatte dazu eine studie
entdeckte diese eruption analysiert und
dann sieht es nicht so gut aus die
sternen stürme könnten mögliches leben
dort verhindern sie könnten die
atmosphären die dort entstanden sein
könnten zerstört haben leben wäre dann
unmöglich ja so viel konjunktiv aber das
ist bei der planetenforschung im moment
noch kaum zu vermeiden zu wenig wissen
wir über die fern sternensysteme und die
sie umkreisenden planeten trabant lsl 40
ps eine super erde das heißt dass der
planet größer und schwerer als die erde
ist genau hat er eine siebenmal größere
masse und mit 18.000 kilometern 14 mal
so großen durchmesser er kreist auf
einer deutlich längeren bahn um den
roten zwerg als um die sonne befindet
sich damit aber genau in der habitablen
also bewohnbaren zone der rote zwerge
deutlich weniger hell sind als die sonne
auf trabant lsl 40 b ist es sogar nur
halb so hell wie hier auf der erde
trotzdem es sind absolut optimale
bedingungen für leben zitat praktisch
der spannendste planet der in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten untergekommen
ist so der hauptautor der studie jason
dittmann vom harvard smithsonian center
for astrophysics in cambridge in den usa
und noch etwas macht ihn zum absoluten
top kandidaten dafür leben auf einem
planeten zu finden
und das macht ihn zu etwas ganz
besonderem alle 25 tage kreis der um
seinen sternen das tut er genau so dass
er vor dem sternen bezug auf uns also
den beobachtungspunkt erde vorbei zieht
das heißt alle 25 tage können wir das
licht das von seinem stern durch seine
atmosphäre zu uns bringt dazu nutzen
seine atmosphäre zu untersuchen
anhand des lichtes können wir nämlich
die zusammensetzung seiner atmosphäre
analysieren und so erfahren ob dort
leben möglich ist oder nicht ein erster
schritt um leben zu finden wir halten
euch hier natürlich auf dem laufenden
media als erstes erfahrt was es am neuen
erkenntnissen zum thema außerirdisches
leben gibt damit ihr nichts mehr was
drückt merkt genau hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht dass die glocke
dann erfahrt ihr von jedem video als
erstes falls wirklich so bisher noch
nicht abonniert habt das habt ihr bisher
verpasst die besten links und videos
meint blutigen science and fiction
klickt euch da mal durch und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt an